now before you you leave let me ask you
am I just your Sifu for seven weeks
remind your seafood for a lifetime of
course of course Sifu yes I'm devoted
you know like he's like every by was
under this impression that we were
destined for greatness you [ __ ]
not one [ __ ] sale made that we are
all just kids that were throwing off the
graduation hats and he just says alright
[ __ ] you want more lessons you want
you really want job
open that [ __ ] wallet give me that
two thousand dollars Laura gave me it
gave me two three thousand give me more
[ __ ] idiots keep it wait why he said
that kiss money you know kiss it touch
it though he's like he's like love money
y'all shame on me I I had fights with my
family members they were telling me dude
this sounds like some cult [ __ ] now I'm
like really
no no you see that's your lower mindset
saying that he said once you imagine
that you're standing on the edge of the
cliff Sifu appears over your shoulder he
says I want you to jump how many of you
would jump there waving there Craig
cards like they don't even know what the
[ __ ] they're buying people I know that
are in debt people that I know who are
starving who haven't found jobs and
they're running to that table one of
these guys I knew that was struggling he
handed his Craig card over to damn logs
lackeys and he said I'm praying that
this goes through
and it did he got to climb and he just
melted on the floor he was crying and
then another guy was like I got to climb
- he's like man if I could sell my soul
right now I would is Dan Locke a cult
yes or no is it hide to get closer I
call it yes or no yes I saw like some of
your other Dan lock videos I was like
man he's just scratching the surface
like if this dude only knew are we gonna
are we gonna open it up today dude are
we gonna do it let's go yes let's open
the lid cuz I mean it's Christmas time I
don't give two [ __ ] and I got my coffee
right here hell yeah going from Dan lock
to coffee Zilla dude I love it good
times man hey hey guys look at this look
at this here oh here
whistle blowing for you guys who are
thinking of joining closers in black
high-ticket closer don't buy before you
watch the video welcome to coffee Zilla
welcome to fake guru I am your Sifu you
were the real Sifu here in the house and
today we've got we've got Garrett who
came forward and he said look you guys
literally ready to reveal everything
I mean I'm ready to open this can of
worms you guys have barely scratched the
surface so take it away I the floor is
yours sure I mean golly gee there
there's so many ways that start but I
guess I'll just start with how I first
began and that would be back in July of
2018 where I've just finished my first
year teaching and I thought man this job
sucks like you it's stressful all year
round what do you teach at that time I
was teaching like three different
elective classes and I'm certified in
English so yeah it was it was nothing
like I was prepared
for and overall I was just doubting
myself I'm like am I cut out to be like
this you know maybe there's another
opportunity and I think I was just a low
point because it's in the middle of
summer vacation and I gotta get ready to
go back into the war zone you know so
it's almost like a Saving Private Ryan
like I'm picturing the war and
everything I'm like oh my really right
for this so and then out of the heavens
this guru came Dan Locke and he said hey
Gary don't don't worry about that I got
I got the solution for you you can quit
your 9:00 to 5:00 I'm going to to give
you the tools to to make six figures you
can quit this race you're you're special
I think that's what hit me you know Dan
dan has a way to make you feel special I
just want Larry bye no I'm not gonna be
like you know busting his ass throughout
this whole thing there there are some
you know there's some things I'll give
him props for but yeah but this was one
thing that you know he knows how to like
talk to an audience directly of course
yeah and make you feel special and the
other thing was that he didn't exactly
just pop up directly to me he popped up
in many of the other channels I was
watching some of you all may be watching
a Stephan james project like mastery or
improvement pill and this guy like knows
how to network with all these new gurus
and such and for the longest time I was
just devouring their content for you
know their free content they always kept
bringing up hey if you want to get rich
you need a high income skill they were
like my friend Dan Locke here teaches a
high income skill so these people I
already hates - hey you want a little
secret here yeah let's say you get back
into that in a second but the secret is
and those people get paid every time
they sell it - I take a closer course
they're not just saying that okay
they're getting a kickback from Dan lock
for that go ahead go ahead but yeah you
try no no definitely I'm glad you
brought that up because yeah they're all
getting kickback in fact
provement pillow lair found out was a
you know mentee of dance so I was just
thinking you all these people I trust
they're all recommending him they're
telling me to come look at this free
masterclass you know the master classes
love it so I jump into this master class
and there he is bringing up the wealth
triangle like okay you know you you you
got everything you need you just need
the high income skill I mean coffee
break look even even just minutes before
this interview Dan and had a video
posted a new video and women she says
hey if you wanna make million Seanie a
high income skill so I heard that over
and over again I just didn't know well
what is a high income skill see he got
me asking to these questions and then
here he comes down from the heavens he's
like here's your high income skill it's
HTC oh oh the black but you see it look
at so holy huh but I I'm sorry I only
have version of the first edition this
is now obsolete you know if I would have
gone to coast closures in black this
year I would have gotten the second dish
and wow this is joke life-changing stuff
yeah but I so throughout this master
class he's bringing up how easy this is
you got a product that's am i selling
for $1000 you get on the phone and you
just close some buy you get a percentage
of it it he makes it sound so easy and
then he's like how what would be like if
I taught you how to do that I was like
who me and he's like yeah you yeah I
could I could I could make you into a
six-figure earner but you know you God
do the work I'm like yes sir I'm ready
to work scouts honor
like I was right to go he's like okay
then click this page so I click the page
and you know these gurus they they
pulled this [ __ ] where you go to this
page and they have a little countdown
like there's a timer but its scarcity
yeah don't do what I did okay I
I jumped on it I went to the page
I saw the countdown clock I saw
availability go down to seven I was
thinking oh [ __ ] I've got to jump on
this like there's only seven
opportunities let me tell you it and you
know I was I was prepped I was groomed
for this because other Stefan James
Project life mastery and improvement
Hill videos told me hey you gotta be
ready to drop like thousands of dollars
if you want a high income skill so I had
the Craig card out I was like yes I've
been mentally ready for this I'm ready
to buy it and I'm thinking as soon as I
buy this it's gonna be me and like 20
other people Dan's gonna personally
mentor us just like how he said in the
video so I dropped that money on my
Craig card didn't even talk to my wife
about at the time which was absolutely
stupid because here we are supposed to
be working like a team but again that's
what that [ __ ] countdown clock does
to you and the veil ability makes you
think like I've got to act now oh my god
so I thought I had no time to think and
stupid me I mean if I would just realize
that this wasn't even a live video these
know it's not a live video there is no
number you can let the clock run all the
way down availability go to zero you'll
click it they let anybody in any burden
at any time yeah there's no scarcity
there's zero scarcity no and just just
think about that everybody think about
that this is your introduction to this
[ __ ] class it is a fake countdown
clock and [ __ ] like I hate that [ __ ]
fake live fake live it's all a lie it's
all I yeah and then and then once you
drop the money you get into the Facebook
group and I'm like these are the people
I'm gonna like get rich with and we're
gonna be sin on yachts like we were
paying the fancies ourselves before
class even started yeah it was I need a
sip after boy look and that's the and
that's the expectation who sets up man
you're gonna be some big high take it
closer like me let me sit let me ask you
this so how much did you spend on that
course okay the course before the up
sale which we'll get to a little bit
was 2500 you know I'm a teacher I I
saved up at this time I I had you know
thousands in the bank I was like yeah
good save a little money drop 2500 and
not break the bank cool so that's why I
did does that surprise you no it no it
doesn't it doesn't surprise me at all I
mean but it's not like you have
thousands of dollars sitting around that
many mattr to you yeah and there was no
um what should I say like a test or no
pre evaluation of whether this program
and was right for you qualify you they
just let anybody in alright so you drop
the money yeah over the course does it
work for you
hell no I mean I mean here's what I'll
say the course god damn just like many
other courses you guys are gonna say I
remember you interviewing somebody else
who went through [ __ ] maybe it was Jason
capitals or some buys course it was like
yeah man but but the mindset like he
taught me all this mindset [ __ ] I'm like
yeah they all teach that [ __ ] the first
two weeks the first two classes are
nothing but the brainwashing I call it
yeah I want you yeah they want you to
feel like you're already rich and that
you have abundant money
um and that you love money and get you
get you in a happy place where you're
motivated alright and then he starts
actually teaching go ahead go ahead
is it true that Dan Locke says you
should have a sexual relationship with
money you know I didn't hear that I'll
be honest I I didn't hear that but he
said you should he said he said you
shouldn't think of money as like dirty
or anything you should love it you know
touch it kiss a keep it around keep it
in drawers okay yeah this might be worse
he's like keep it wait why he said that
kiss money you know kiss it touch it
though he's like he's like love money
y'all keep it keep it all over your
house just so so it didn't dawn me like
why is he making us feel like this you
know but but it all comes at the
end of the course watch it all builds up
- so after two weeks with mindset you
get three weeks of the martial arts how
to close all right you gotta know your
your your your prospects and how to
deflate objections and all that stuff
like a kung fu master and let me tell
you that's it that's how he frames it
you have to be a kung fu master of class
right that's right you got flow like
water like Bruce Lee oh
if they throw an objection huh do that
and come back with a question and you
got it well later when I was actually
trying to close that [ __ ] did not work
but anyway well we'll get to that
oh so three weeks of that and by this
time it was tough for me doing my job
and handling the homework assignments
for HTC because they give you homework
Assad but you can't just slack off right
right so I'm I'm back at school I'm
teaching and Dan I mean just the way the
course is structured it's made to build
to make you feel great and make you like
you all you should you should not be
worried about spending money because
you're gonna get all back if you're
making six figures you're gonna make
that money back so this is where I'm a
probably the most crucial mistakes of my
life I quit my job and yeah I quit my
job and I said because I know this is
gonna work
yeah and coffee I wasn't the only one
there were not only were there people
encouraging me to quit but there were
people who had quit in like week one or
two they said [ __ ] you to their bosses
gave him the mill finger walked out like
everybody was under this impression that
we were destined for greatness yeah
whoa that's dark it is it gets worse cuz
um so again I mean I have some thousands
of dollars in the bank to to keep me
afloat for about four months all right
so I'm thinking cool I devote four
months to closing hell if I can't close
the deal by the end of those four months
it's my fault
that's the other thing is your car made
to believe like it's always your fault
if not if something's work it's your
fault
it's that lower mindset ma'am cuz Sifu
knows so if seafood seafood can't be
wrong if something's wrong it's your
it's the it's your fault for sure it's
your lower mindset your your yeah but
then comes the last two weeks which is
about how to get a job and this is the
one I'm like alright let's hear it he's
like alright so here's what you do you
be nice to them you give value and
they'll give you a job what kind of jobs
can you get with closing well you can
sell cars boats the sky's the limit man
just go go out and sell [ __ ] I'm like oh
I I thought there was like a process to
this okay cuz I thought he just pushes
you a kind of he's like he's like you
were expecting him to have a pipeline
some kind of formula for getting a job
right because I mean I was me I was
feeling special like I'm a mentee of Dan
lock like there's gotta be like aren't
the companies climbing at Dan locks
window to hire us ya know and he said
that in the Masterclass video he said
there are countless jobs it's a blue
ocean out there they're all climbing for
you and he's and at the end he's just
like good luck but and then the last
class he pulls this [ __ ] and coffee I
honestly if if he would just push us off
and said that's the class have a nice
day I honestly wouldn't be here I'd be
like okay I lost out twenty five hundred
bucks but you know it's my bad I'll live
and from what I learned you know if you
have no sales experience I guess like
it's an it's an okay introduction if
you've never read a sales book if you've
never read influenced by Robert Cialdini
if you've never and you only you're only
introduction is Dan lock yes but if you
only knew that everything you learned is
available in about three books that are
about ten bucks apiece then tell me how
you'd feel about spending 25
dollars for sure but III hear what
you're saying you don't want to have a
life regrets I understand that the
mindset I understand the mindset no yeah
and I like I said honestly if it was
stopped there
I was said okay you got yeah yeah one no
yeah but then he brings up like okay so
I know you guys are worried about
getting a job but I got this inner
circle you know you can join you and I
will make sure we will work our asses
off to make sure you get a job now
before you you leave let me ask you am I
just your Sifu for seven weeks or mind
your seafood for a lifetime so our our
hearts are racing like we built a
connection with this guy oh man wait of
course of course Sifu yes I'm devoted
you know we can't we can't disappoint
him we what can we do Sifu yes yes we'll
follow you anywhere he's like okay well
wallet that's exactly how much do you
think it cost to get into that I just
you just you just spent twenty five
hundred to three grand for this course
how much more to get into inner circle
well it's only a low price of just an
additional $2,000 more you [ __ ] not
one [ __ ] sale made we are all just
kids that were throwing off the
graduation hats and he just says all
right [ __ ] you want more lessons you
want you really want job open that
[ __ ] wallet give me that two thousand
dollars you are a gave me it gave me two
three thousand give me more [ __ ]
idiots
so and he's doing this live on class
like like anybody who jumps in he's got
he's got sergeant Desmond his right-hand
man naming off people who have already
joined so there's that
that that heard feeling like oh I'm
missing out oh no wait Geoffrey
Geoffrey's in the inner circle oh wait I
like Geoffrey Arnold's in it oh I gotta
go fault I got joined now so so
everybody like I would say a good 80% or
more of students joined inner circle
that night Wow yeah and a part of it was
yes you're guaranteed a job about we're
okay not guarantee but we will work your
ass off three months he makes the
implant implication you're gonna get a
job you're gonna get a job you're gonna
get a job and that's and that's what
gets me is that so much of this [ __ ] he
can throw it back on you'd be like oh I
never said that but it's like dude you
pretty much said everything but that
like you molded us to do this so we're
all jumping in to this giant pool I'm
going down the [ __ ] rabbit hole and
remember my plan I'm supposed to be
living off this money for the next four
months well that's now cut down to two
months and then I I find out it's not
just two grand okay you have to pay an
additional two hundred dollars each and
every month because what you're Ginn is
totally worth that again
one [ __ ] class each month a brand new
class I'm like really okay but you know
just like my just like the other guy you
had on I wanted a [ __ ] job you're
right right and yeah yeah as soon as I
get there they post an opportunity and
we all jump on it and it was this uh
this woman trying to sell like a
coaching service or whatnot and she had
this like making application take a test
resume cover letter introduction be like
seven different [ __ ] things and
everybody jumps on this [ __ ] and the
very next day she cave on is running
this and he posts he shows us a
screenshot of an email from her saying
hey your students did not a lot of your
students didn't do all seven of the
tasks I asked I'm not personally
Matthieu but it makes me wonder what
kind of students you're teaching over
there
and then he he posts guys why should we
keep why do we work our asses off to
give you these opportunities if this is
how you you make the brand look like why
should we keep giving you jabs I'm like
you [ __ ] we just paid 2 grand for this
don't act like you know this is a pretty
big favor to us yeah
so and not only that but my fellow
brothers and sisters in HTC who we would
were brothers and sisters that's what we
call each other all right so if you
thought it was like a call it was like a
call and he he so all my brothers and
sisters who I've went through class with
guess what they start saying in the
comments section throw these [ __ ] out
there bad apples get rid of them
yeah save it for us and all that [ __ ]
I'm like what the [ __ ] like wait we were
family
and suddenly it's now like doggy-dog
world and yeah a few people spoke up and
they got like you know they got jumped
on by all the other members so that was
my first indication that this was a bad
idea but hey at least I got to go to
closures in black because I was in the
air circle right that's a big thing what
so tell everybody what closures in black
is so cool by the way by the way for
everyone not now realizing now we have
three upsells or two upsells so far for
sure got we've got hi to get closer then
when hi to get closer doesn't get you a
job they promise you closers in black no
inner circle there's our circle sorry
it's hard to keep up with them like
double the price and they almost promise
you a job and then and then they upsell
you to closures in black yeah now wait
wait and let's go back because now we
have Dan on demand which is kind of a
way to upsell you into HTC so for me
there was one less step but now there's
an extra step you guys listen Dan on
demand Dan on the man that's like a
service that he's providing for $50 a
month you have like one one
Q&A session with him you know a bunch of
other people like and and and you know
I'll get into this you know I hope we
have time so much to talk about but
basically yeah he had HTC students like
anybody who was interested in HTC from
Dan on the man he would seek out these
students to go and like try and close
them like yeah like like like sharks you
know they smell blowing the water go go
Kim get him get him into the program but
hey it's not a pyramid scheme he
stressed that over and over this is not
MLM [ __ ] that [ __ ]
well it's funny because he's got a lot
of MLM components because a lot of the
students end up trying to close for Dan
in the end yeah yeah and and it's funny
most of the successful closers work for
Dan mm-hmm interesting so let me ask you
this let me ask you this people are
gonna say I already know what the
comment is oh this guy's just salty cuz
he didn't work hard right what do you
have to say to those people I mean damn
I had I had over a hundred hours you
know trying to close real customers I've
tried to make this [ __ ] work like I was
working with the team which we'll get
into later this is after closers in
black and we worked with probably a
dozen different influencers and
influencers these are the people who are
selling high ticket packages like
thousands of dollars I tell you none of
us was close and [ __ ]
alright so you can you can you can hate
on me you can say I'm salty but I know
hundreds of people that this is not
working and the only ones it seems to be
working for are those that now work for
Dan who are now selling Dan lock more of
Dan locks product exactly and there
anyone cycle
yep hey he's Dan lock a cult yes or no
is it high to get closer a cult yes or
no yes yeah oh my god
I'm gonna I'm gonna say yeah and you
know shame on me I I had fights with my
family members they were telling me dude
this sounds like some cold [ __ ]
I'm like really no no you see that's
your lower mindset saying that you know
and he's like you call these people you
don't know brothers and sisters yeah
because we're trying to be you know
we're not living in the matrix like you
we're out of the matrix where we're in
the real world we we know each other we
understand each other and yeah dude it's
a it's a cult but I don't even think Dan
knows it's a cult
I think he's he's drinking so much of
his own kool-aid I he thinks that he is
really making a difference in the world
but he's building this Empire on the
bodies of you know innocent people who
are throwing away their money so and
their job and their jobs like myself
included just to skip ahead I am a
teacher again and it's actually great so
yeah there's a bit of happy good good
I'm happy to hear that I'm really happy
to hear that all right but I want to get
into closers in black because this was
this was like the thing where oh my
whole reality shattered so one of the
privileges with being part of the inner
circle is you get to attend closers in
black what is closures in black what did
I know about that time I don't [ __ ]
know
he just said be there because there's
gonna be learning there's gonna be
surprises there's gonna be a law
breakthroughs so I'm like oh man this is
something like Tony Robbins [ __ ] oh yeah
but the best part was I like I built the
connection with a lot of these people in
the program I was like I get to meet
them hang out with them and we get to
feel like millionaires were dressed in
tuxedos and [ __ ] so I'm like yeah let's
let's do this so it's totally free you
just have to pay to get there
oh and seafood demands that you stay at
the hotel where this is happening all
right at this point I'm like Sifu knows
everything if I do not stay at this
hotel I am [ __ ]
like I'm dead so I end up spending I
would say close to over a grand to get
there the flight the hotel room yeah so
my plan of surviving for four months has
now diminished to a month and a half but
again it's no worries I'm gonna make
this money really quick I'm gonna get a
closing job and money's just gonna roll
right in well I fly out to closures in
black Vancouver awesome said he loved it
go inside and closes in black it was
great got to see a lot of my fellow
cohort and stuff but some of the warning
signs I was Ginn though was I was
meeting a lot of season one students and
here's the thing I noticed um
about a couple months after her season
ends a lot of the students kind of
stopped posting on Facebook they kind of
vanish then you know they'll have HTC or
on their banner they'll be dressed in
suits and they they were regularly
posting but then a couple months after
the program ended it stops so I'm like
hey dude how's everything going and they
would just be like ah you know I'm
struggling not I'm not closing and all
so I'm like oh [ __ ] and so I'm like so
why aren't you [ __ ] like I'm ashamed
and this the story kept repeating they
were ashamed they you know because they
while in the program they're proudly
announcing I'm HTC I'm a [ __ ]
high ticket closer but then when you're
out in the real world and you're not
closing you're like oh wow I've let
seafood down I've let myself down I'm a
failure you know you just kind of you
gotta back away from social media and
it's really because this wood layer
happened to me as well
um but though I was already gained red
flags and then the first day was nothing
but mostly have Dan having Desmond and
Kavon give speeches and the theme of the
speeches were sort of hey trust Dan
trust him he's he's got he it in fact oh
so like deaths it's like you know I
trusted Dan and my whole life changed
kayvon gets up i trusted dan and my
whole life change which is funny because
later dan goes against Kavon right yep
bursaries yeah we're close to one-year
anniversary of that [ __ ] [ __ ] man
that was some good drama that was that
was one of the funniest days of my life
I'll be honest but we'll get to that sec
ah good [ __ ] okay
so came on at one point asks everybody
to stand up he said once you imagine
that you're standing on the edge of the
cliff Sifu appears over your shoulder
and he says I want you to jump how many
of you would jump and I kill you now we
all looked at each other and we were
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] of course there was
a few dumbasses you were like what the
[ __ ] I cannot make this [ __ ] yeah you're
not making this up I could tell because
this is too this is too real they ask
you they ask you let me get it straight
if Sifu who is standing over your
shoulders creepily over your shoulders
would you would you Jeff oh yeah and I
mean some were like yes I would I trust
Sifu and and Laird that I mean yeah but
but but here's the thing now listen
everybody pay attention because again a
majority of the room was looking at HR
like oh like no so we we weren't we
weren't fully convinced yet all right
hmm and even layer that night we were me
and like a bunch of other people were
sing around like in the lobby of the
hotel and we one of the guys okay I'm
not going to name names but one of the
guys who was a devoted like Dan Locke
fan was just [ __ ] talking him
alright and believe it or not this guy's
working for Dan right now so I'm soon
with this guy devoted fan and he's just
[ __ ] talking him and saying like oh man
he's like the the influencers I'm
working with because he's actually he
actually found an influencer
um and he was actually making some money
it was selling like one of these Amazon
you know FTC classes or whatever great
FDA whatever it is yeah he was
yeah FBA yeah I get that [ __ ] confused
but he was telling me that the people he
was working for they were even like oh
man Dan Locke yeah the whole HTC thing
like we were actually close to not hard
you because that so everybody pay the
[ __ ] attention even the people who are
selling high ticket packages they're all
getting together and they know that the
value of HTC students are not that great
so Spencer who came on the show he said
I tried
he had a course he tried HTC closers and
the up trash no yeah yeah and I mean you
cannot expect seven classes to
completely make someone into a sales
expert but that's what Dan you know
preaches and unfortunately even at this
time the brand was damaged this guy told
me so he said this brand is damaged I'm
probably he he literally told me I'm
probably gonna leave
HTC heir circle right after this and a
lot of people I was sitting with agreed
all right so the same group I'm with
tonight we show up the next day and we
all were talked about we're like we're
right for this up sale
he's like everything yesterday was
prepping us for an up sale I was like
[ __ ] so he starts off with a little
story about the guy who starred Alibaba
and he was like how he started that with
16 people and he wants to now start a
big movement and he's like the number
I'm looking for is 300 I'm looking for
300 Spartans to work with me to fight
with me to make this brand what it is
and
I was like oh [ __ ] here he comes and
he's like ladies and gentlemen
introducing the third pillar the inner
circle of the inner circle high ticket
millionaire everybody
he said imagined okay he loves that word
imagine you imagine you got a job yeah
for sure that's what we all [ __ ] won
but he's like no [ __ ] that [ __ ] here's
what you do
yeah you lead a team of ten closers they
close for you they get half their profit
and you get half that profit Bob being
Bob boom you're gonna be if everybody's
making a hundred thousand you're also
making a hundred thousand so you're
essentially making a million dollars and
I'm going to take 300 of you and make
you into millionaires within the next
three years so now everybody's like
perking up and I'm just like still
slumped like what the [ __ ] I just
graduated wait I'm qualified to lead a
team like no this is Gabbie for like
season one people right now it's it's
open for everybody even even thus even
seasoned sticks people who graduated a
week before this we're in that room and
they were given this opportunity so they
were up sailed three times within the
span of like two months here much as I
take a millionaire we'll get it there
first we got a god talk about the
bonuses coffee I mean that's that's the
point the bonuses you get to fly you get
to attend these meetings in the most
extravagant places like Hawaii I'm
trying to think where was the second one
he did but you I mean you got paid for
your own flight there in your own hotel
room but you get to come and you know
come and come for a a class exclusively
to how run a business and then you also
get more access to Dan you can call them
up for like an hour you get to you know
get get your own class once a month
okay and then he stopped he said I'm
looking around the room and I could see
some some real eager people who are
ready to make that first move advantage
so before I even revealed the price if
you even want to hear the [ __ ] price
go to the back table and sign up now and
holy [ __ ] you remember that scene from
The Lion King with the Stampede coming
down symbols like that was me because I
was sitting near the back of the room
and I see this whole [ __ ] stampede of
hundreds of people running towards the
back table there they're waving their
Craig cards like they don't even know
what the [ __ ] they're buying they're
slamming the table and I'm like it
almost so bad get run over I see people
who don't have a pot to piss in running
to that table people I know that are in
debt people that I know who are starving
who haven't found jobs and they're
running to that table and I'm like what
the [ __ ] is this madness
I sit down my table I'm like can you
believe this [ __ ] and the two guys next
to me one of which was the guy who was
you know saying how this was complete
[ __ ] he's like this is cool I'm gonna
join ya meet Stu I was like oh gosh we
talked about this last night like he's
this is a joke and and then I turned to
the guy to my right I'm like what do you
think about this dude and he's like yeah
I'll know about this I'm like dude it's
like we just graduated martial arts
school
we're blue belts we haven't closed a
single [ __ ] package but he he wants
us he's given us a chance to buy a black
belt and call ourselves a black belt I'm
like that this isn't right like I'm I
haven't sold a single package I
shouldn't be leading a team how can you
coach people to sell sell right yeah
especially some of these season six
people who just graduated just join
inner circle and now you can be a high
ticket millionaire well he me and him
are both on the same page for a good
five minutes but then Dan says so the
cost of the program
is five grand a month but but just for
you guys in this room okay
50% 50% off so only 2500 a month bro
this is a clown world man he's I've got
so many bad things to say about Dan lock
I don't even know it I I don't know but
but coffee nobody told you about this
like am i I have never heard of this
this is insane Wow how much money have
people lost with this guy well let me
put it this way one of these guys I knew
that was struggling he handed his Craig
card over to Dan Locke's lackeys and he
said I'm praying that this goes through
and it didn't he got declined and he
just melted on the floor he was crying
and then another guy was like I got
declined - he's like man if I could sell
my soul right now I would I'm look out
Mike you're joking he's like I would
there this is turning it into like a
[ __ ] nightmare
he wasn't that that other guy wasn't the
only one there were people crying
they're so in debt that they can't buy
anymore of Dan lock stuff but but they
feel like they're lend seafood down and
and they're they're just they're like no
I need this I need this they really
believe that joining this program was
gonna make them millionaires and I
remembered like this was some Hollywood
movie [ __ ] I'm standing there and I'm
looking at Dan directly like rheya him
of course he doesn't notice me I mean
he's look he's smiling look at all these
guys and my hands are just clenched I'm
so angry at this guy I'm like this is
not right
this isn't right you should not be
except from some of these people's mind
right now they are struggling starving
out of jobs and you're promising them to
be millionaires and you're charging them
twenty five hundred a month like puke
man and then
sit down and I'm like man this is [ __ ]
up and then the guide next to me to my
right it's like you know what I'm going
for it I'm like what the [ __ ]
coffee by the end of that that [ __ ]
day there I would guarantee Dan had more
than 300 people Dan had he had to have
sold this [ __ ] to at least 600 people
and I wondered I wondered like how did
he pay for all this the car he have
sports car in the room he had lights he
had food and then it hit me I was like
we paid for this [ __ ] just now he said
this everything cost five hundred
thousand where he get that five hundred
thousand he made it in that very moment
and there's these vacations he's talking
about giving classes at who's paying for
his room and his vacation he found a
consistent source of income of thousands
of dollars every month and all he did
all he had to do was sell more access to
himself and that's when it hit me like
this this is [ __ ] up so so thankfully
um those two you know because I left
this place expecting a job like I was
going networked with somebody good job
and thankfully the two guys I was sin
with at the table you know mad respect
to them they gave me they saw they saw
they saw something in me and they they
let me on their team you know their team
and from there on that's when they
started trying to close influencers and
I started trying to close for them and
there was just no success eventually one
of them the guy who was shit-talking Dan
eventually got promoted and Dan picked
him up and now he's working for Dan
right now and you know good cheers man
good for you you looked like you're
happy so that's cool but you know my
other friend he's still he's still
working at it the other guys still work
at I have a guy is the other guy in
they're both in high tech a millionaire
right yeah
and there's a boat and hey Dan Locke
$2,500 a month yeah but from from what I
can't apply like they don't seem worried
because I guess Dan taught them how they
can work that into their taxes to get
back bro you never get that back
I yeah but that's what they're believing
and that's what it's like scare me I'm
like okay and even if that is true like
your credits gonna be garbage oh they're
never dude I can't imagine people I
would look oh man I bet some people have
lost over ten grand just on Dan ezel for
sure for surely easy I mean coffee think
about this um oh [ __ ] what was I even
gonna say hey yeah I was just gonna say
um yeah I mean even everybody really
thought they were gonna be millionaires
man Dan brought them out onto a lot a
yacht that night and the whole yacht was
[ __ ] packed like I asked them how was
the dinner he's like no one could barely
move around the yacht that's how many
people joined this [ __ ] program and I
have not met a single [ __ ] person
Partha who is anywhere close to becoming
a millionaire right now it's a reverse
Robin Hood yeah you take from the poor
give to the rich that's right and coffee
I know I remember I was gonna say if
let's pretend yeah like they they're now
in a hole of debt prayers
take them now they're in desperate need
there's no one else to turn to but Dan
right right
and I'm like god damn like that was that
was say what you want about Dan that was
a that was a calculated like he had to
have calculated this and it it you could
say was smart at the same time like you
don't realize the Matt damage you did
you took a bunch of unskilled people
like myself and you just you just
suckered us and I I remember talking
with one guy I'm like oh so you joined
high ticket millionaire um how you feel
about that have you closed he said no
and I said well you know why do you feel
like you're qualified to lead a team
then they said well Sifu always says
trust the process
so he wouldn't have given us this
opportunity if he didn't believe in us I
was like okay I'm what's your name I
looked at his name I'm like okay cool
I'm gonna remember that I'm gonna check
up on you a year from now let's see how
where you are when did you discover
coffee still I'm kind of curious dude it
Isis covered you like about couple weeks
ago and okay yeah and I guess um I must
have popped up while I was watching one
of Dan Locke's videos and
I remember watching some of the things
you expose like that call he did know
what Desmond's call where he comes in
he's like hey I got go you you know I
remember watching that and think it was
real but then you broke it down and like
told me how fake it is and I thought
yeah I really wish there was a channel
like this that could saved me from
making this huge mistake let's let's
calculate let's calculate what it meant
to your net worth to find Dan Bock okay
so you spent two grand right well you
spent twenty five hundred total let's
start let's do that 25 points we'll pull
up all right so you spent twenty five
hundred yeah then you spent two thousand
dollars in the up so yep okay how many
months were you in it's obviously two
hundred dollars a month
oh [ __ ] six months and then you spent
$1,000 on the trip and then you quit
your job so you were out of your
paycheck for how many months from the
time you quit to when you got a job six
months okay six months and so it just
ballpark how much money that would be so
at that time is about twenty-two hundred
a month all right now I'm gonna add all
this up because I want you guys at home
to really feel feels a sting oh yeah
yeah cuz they end it well but dude this
is like it's not a cheap thing $19,000
$900 so $20,000 damn okay well you're
good man I just did on a calculator
$20,000 would be further for joining Dan
Locke's course yep everybody at home if
you guys don't think these guys are
predatory think about that twenty
thousand dollars it's a twenty thousand
dollar mistake and I'm not ragging on
you
I'm not ragging on you I'm literally
saying it because we're people at home
need to know this man it is not like
people think oh it's it's only a course
it's only $2,000 first of all a lot of
people don't have $2,000 in the bank
this
he had his life together so he was able
to do it but 20 think about what you
could do with $20,000 right now right
now you're gonna add $20,000 to your
pocket I could be putting a down payment
on a house right now and be moving along
with my with my life you know getting
ready to have kids that that [ __ ] has
now taken a backseat because I have to
first get out of debt because I don't
want to start having kids while I'm in
yeah get from this you're in deaf you
still em cuz cuz let me tell you when
when you go back to teaching you're not
making a full salary if you jump back in
the middle of the year so I only just
started making a full salary how long
were you making like a prorated salary
like you know like half rate yeah yeah
yeah that was since March so that
another six months of hat like of a half
salary yeah over half sour just enough
just enough to pay the bills not not pay
any extra on the Craig okay hold on let
me let me let me add that in then that's
like $26,000 there's a twenty six
thousand dollar mistake 26 and I'm sorry
to say I mean thank you so you're here
Oh pleasure
this is why I do the show that's $26,000
are you listening everyone at home
are you listening $26,000
thank you Dan Locke thanks Dan hi Dan I
know you're watching this I didn't say
hi hey Dan hey hey Sifu c-44 life dude
that is brutal that's brutal
yeah it's so it's it's horrible but you
don't know when you're getting in you
think it's only twenty five hundred
dollars that's right
you do not expect the up-sales you don't
expect the what it'll do to you what
your fit your family then gets involved
it causes strain in your family it's
terrible I mean that mindset [ __ ] you
know that all these gurus teach they do
that in the first couple weeks not not
to make you a better person but to get
you on board with
the program and you know you suck you
win guys like don't honestly like you
said there are books out there there are
many resources and when you see these
master classes you're thinking that
these guys are gonna be holding your
hand with you one every step of the way
mentoring you one-on-one like if you're
something special
you're just a herd of sheep they're just
guiding you so you know say what you
want you you a lot of people can be like
dude you know well that's your fault for
queen your job but hey I'm one of
hundreds hundreds if not thousands of
people in that program who did the same
thing everyone I knew quit their jobs
the only advice is you have the courage
to speak out about it exactly and i i i
guess parmi was ashamed just like
everybody else a lot of people are
ashamed that's why a lot of people don't
come forward oh yeah oh yeah there are
people watching right now who aren't
going to come forth and look I'm not
gonna force you to come come out and say
something but it's it's because it's
terrible it's shameful it's like how did
I get myself scam that it's because it's
an orchestrated thing he uses your
psychology against you I mean exactly
and hey that [ __ ] like a once you go
against the family you're never allowed
back in and yeah it plays on your mind
but you know excommunicate oh yeah well
you know what it took it took me uhm
losing my older brother back in March he
passed away and yeah it that that was
the moment that took me like I just lost
a real brother a real person who would
stand by me and be there to help me and
although I have these people on the
Internet and they're cool and all but I
have a real family and I was happy with
them and I feel like a lot a lot of
people they feel unfulfilled because
they didn't have what I had like a real
family to say around and you know that
saying you don't realize what you have
until it's gone but man losing my
brother put a long perspective we only
have one life you know
and you can't [ __ ] this [ __ ] up and what
I did
wounded me financially it wounded um it
wounded my marriage a bit it wounded my
relationship with my family
it goes beyond so much the money um it's
a miracle while I've been able to do
these past couple of months to put my
life back together again congratulations
and thank you sorry to hear about your
brother I appreciate that man yeah it
was unexpected but it really opened my
eyes and I feel like now I'm you know
now I'm happy it's like here I was
worrying about getting rich and all but
a lot of us around we we don't need to
be rich to be happy all right
and it's those thoughts that we're like
the special one we're the star of our
own movie we're destined for greatness
those are the thoughts that they want
you to feel and they will prey on you
for feeling that way so go out there do
great things you know don't be a cheap
person and if you can produce a service
or a product or an idea that makes you
Millions hey congratulations
but don't [ __ ] use these
psychological tactics like these people
these fake gurus because they're not in
it to improve your life one bit they're
there to destroy your life and to make
themselves look at you at the end of the
day closers in black
dan Locke has pictures standing on stage
with hundreds of people standing up and
plotting him that's all we were we were
a photo op for him our bank
shrinking our families ripped apart our
our relationships damage also he can
look like a God among men that's Dan
Locke
that's tough man that's tough to hear
guys we're gonna wrap it there this has
gotten heavy this has gotten real heavy
but I think but I think honestly look we
make fun of the Guru's it's fun to have
a laugh you know it's it's it is fun
because it's because they're so
ridiculous but at the end of the day you
need to realize these things have
consequences and I wish these gurus knew
they had consequences I've gotten in
contact with a lot of gurus and I always
ask them the same question how do you
I don't word it this met like way but I
basically say how do you live with
yourself how do you sleep at night and
all of them have some varying answer of
oh well I don't think it's that bad I
don't think it's people who can't afford
it joining my course
buh buh buh buh buh look at who is in
your course look who's leaving your
course they never look back they're
always on selling the next guy they
never look what their course is doing
and it's messing up people's lives guys
that's it we're in there
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
or the car
[Music]